anti-abortion activists demonstrating
outside mexico's supreme court on
tuesday they're protesting a landmark
decision by mexico's high court
declaring that the criminalization of
abortion in the state of cuahuilla is
unconstitutional
the unanimous ruling sets a precedent
for the decriminalization of abortion
nationwide
ladies and gentlemen ministers today is
a historic day for the rights of all
mexican women and pregnant people
from this moment on it will not be
possible to prosecute any woman who has
an abortion in the cases that this
constitutional court has considered
valid
[Music]
women's groups and advocates of abortion
rights are celebrating what they call a
watershed moment
the court has spoken abortion should not
be punitive it should not be
criminalized
this resolution will give legal recourse
to women who today are imprisoned to
regain their freedom
experts warn that while the wheels are
in motion for the decriminalization of
abortion across mexico
it will continue to inflame divisions in
a country with deep conservative
catholic traditions
with this decision by the supreme court
mexico becomes the most populous country
in latin america to move toward
decriminalization of abortion mexico is
also one of the most catholic countries
in the world and conservative rights
groups have vowed to continue to push
back against the court's decision on
abortion rights
the move in favor of abortion in mexico
comes at a time when across the border
u.s states are restricting women's
access to terminations particularly
texas many in mexico believe tuesday's
court ruling will eventually allow u.s
women to turn to mexico for safe and
legal abortions that women will no
longer be prosecuted
that that would include all all women
not only mexican women but mexican
territory
but as it does not mean that services
have to be provided as such then we
won't be expecting necessarily that
women from texas would find more access
to services in mexico than they would in
their own country but this is what we
would be aspiring to in the near future
mexico's president not an outspoken
proponent of abortion rights stressed
that the decision was the courts to make
and promise not to interfere
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city